[Music]
on this Monday night America on edge the
family of George Floyd calls for peace
not violence as the country braces for
what's next who is showing leadership
and where is President Trump racism is
not confined to America as a country we
can't pretend that racism doesn't exist
here Plus how kovat 19 is having a
disproportionate impact on racialized
communities the probable cause of that
snowbirds crash in Kamloops plus what's
underreported in America the compassion
the Solidarity the signs of hope in the
midst of all the mayhem
global national with Donna freezin
on the Minneapolis Street where George
Floyd took his last breath we're police
officers kneeled on him for almost nine
minutes they gathered not to protest but
to pray his brother Terence pleading
with those who across America are
looting and being violent to find
another way know who you're voting for
violence he says won't lead to change
and is not what his family wants they
want justice all four officers have been
fired only one has been charged with
murder now a private autopsy paid for by
the family shows George George Floyd
died of asphyxia at the scene and not
just because one officer had his knee
lodged on his neck but because three
others were also kneeling on his back
the outrage is a powerful force and a
week after Floyd died it is still
building the National Guard is now
mobilized in 24 American states 67,000
military reservists on the streets the
largest number ever activated in the
u.s. in Kentucky a man was shot and
killed during a protest the National
Guard and the police were trying to
disperse tonight President Trump doubled
down on the demonstrators who he has
called thugs he appeared in the White
House rose garden tonight and struck a
law-and-order tone threatening to call
in the military if more governor's don't
deploy the National Guard if a city or
state refuses to take the actions that
are necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents then I will
deploy the United States military and
quickly solve the problem for them
before President Trump appeared there in
the Rose Garden he ordered troops to
fire tear gas at protesters peaceful
protesters who were gathered near the
White House so the area would be clear
and he could walk across the street for
a photo-op which he did after that
little speech in the Rose Garden
Global's Jackson cross Co is near there
for us tonight
Jackson give us a sense of the tone and
the message from the president tonight
Donna it was all about law and order all
about sending strong signals that he
wanted to crack down on days of protests
activity that at one point in his speech
he even labeled as being domestic
terrorism that was carefully timed to
coincide with the crowds being cleared
out from outside the White House there
were some warnings given to the crowd
not everyone heard those warnings but
police have advanced on what was
essentially an entirely peaceful protest
there was no sense of this but we did
see National Guard troops and riot
police fortify the White House grounds
and then move on that crowd so suddenly
so that as you mentioned the president
could carry out that photo-op across the
street Jackson you know there probably
are people in these crowds who are
taking advantage of the situation and
being violent and doing things you know
a whole bunch of groups are coalescing
around this movement but there is real
outrage in the United States over what
happened in Minneapolis over the death
of this man and is the president aware
of that in any way and doing any
messaging to try and and calm that anger
and offer some kind of solution the
sense we've had over the past few days
is that the White House does not have a
message or a strategy when it comes to
hearing the concerns of Americans
especially the black community about the
tactics used by police and the death of
so many black Americans at their hands
and that is why the president instead
has struck up this law-and-order tone in
fact he had a conference call today with
many state governors he called them weak
for refusing to crack down on these
protests he has been almost singularly
focused on the violent aspect of the
protests and the people he feels are
behind it which he labels as Anti Fog
which is far left-wing ideology it's not
a specific group but he's also
threatened to brand them as domestic
terrorists so
perhaps not a surprise that he struck
this heavy-handed tone today but you're
right Donna that question of how he
deals with the healing with the racial
divide in this question that looms over
all of this and few will be satisfied by
strictly a militarized or heavy police
crackdown across the country Jackson
Proust Co near the White House tonight
thank you outside Washington tensions
are also rising tonight Eric Sorenson
brings us more on the situation across
the United States as protests across the
u.s. have multiplied a pattern has
emerged first peaceful demonstrations
daily against racial injustice but at
night that powerful message has become
contentious there has been violence and
some looting the police are seen as both
tamping down and escalating tensions but
the profound pain African Americans feel
is undeniable imagine if it was your son
on the ground screaming I can't breathe
help me a new autopsy commissioned by
George Floyd's family has found he died
of asphyxiation from neck compression
and from officers on his back
contradicting the official autopsy that
cited underlying health issues he
couldn't breathe asphyxia due to
compression of the neck and of the back
and that's homicidal many police are
demonstrating their solidarity with
protesters that the tactics used in
Minneapolis do not represent all cops
among those bridging the divide Flint
Michigan Sheriff Chris Swanson at a time
like this
the US president can be a force for
calming a nation in crisis radical but
many believe President Trump is
politicizing the moment attacking
left-wing groups there are white
supremacist critics say Trump is
ignoring international and right-wing
instigators there are people who are
burning down the institutions that are
core to the our identity all of this
comes during the Cova 19 pandemic twin
crises simultaneously the unrest
disregarding physical distancing which
could make the virus spread and to some
there's no question which risk is
greater if I walk upon the streets
doesn't like me or did something or look
like I'm doing something wrong he can
shoot me right there the scale of the
emergencies is unprecedented
the US National Guard has called out
more than 60,000 troops the largest in
its history 17,000 National Guard
mobilized for civil unrest on top of
45,000 for the coronavirus response but
many celebrities are among those
sympathizing and demonstrating ariana
grande joined a March in Los Angeles
Nick Cannon went to Minneapolis to
protest and Beyonce posted this on
Instagram
no more senseless killings of human
beings no more seeing people of color as
less than human we can no longer look
away for many African Americans the
coronavirus may be temporary the fear of
racial violence against them never ends
Erik Sorensen Global News President
Barack Obama has a message for the
demonstrators about how to sustain
momentum to bring about real change he
says it's not a choice between protests
or politics that it takes both in an
essay published today Obama writes we
have to mobilize to raise awareness and
we have to organize and cast our ballots
to make sure that we elect candidates
who will act on reform if going forward
we can channel our justifiable anger and
into peaceful sustained and effective
action then this moment can be a real
turning point in our nation's long
journey to live up to our highest ideals
not all the protests have been violent a
little later we look at the stories
getting less attention the remarkable
moments of unity the messages of peace
including from police a large crowd
filled one of Halifax's main streets
this evening calling for an end to
racism and justice for George Floyd
hundreds of people took to their need to
honor Floyd he stayed there for eight
minutes and 46 seconds that's the length
of time Minneapolis police officer
Darren Chauvin had his knee on George
Floyd's neck
all of this is taking place in the midst
of a pandemic when people are supposed
to be avoiding large crowds public
health experts are worried about a spike
in cases of kovat 19 and then ten days
to two weeks from now in the u.s. here
in Canada there's some optimism about
where the numbers are right now as much
of the country continues to reopen
abigail Beeman walks us through what's
changing and where it may be a familiar
sound at daycare drop-off but not much
here is the same
how many distance you have to keep
between your friend in Montreal the
country's colvett 19 epicenter daycares
are open with reduced capacity and new
rules we are very ready I told the staff
it's a chess game it may be one step
forward two steps back we're gonna
readjust we're very confident that our
school is clean organized prepared and
safe confidence in BC to where case
numbers are much lower elementary
schools are open attendance is voluntary
not all parents or students are ready he
really wanted to yeah very across the
country dozens of national parks are
opening gradually including Banff
Alberta hurting for tourist dollars but
for now openings are targeted at locals
it's day use only big steps in Manitoba
which starts phase two of reopening with
no new cases Monday and no one in
hospital now pools are open recreational
sports back on and restaurants already
allowed to operate patios can see people
inside at half capacity it does
definitely feel like we're coming out
the other side but I am skeptical and
and nervous as well a different picture
province to province but everyone needs
the same things to move forward to give
businesses the confidence to reopen
their doors and people the confidence to
walk through those doors we need to
cooperate on countrywide testing and
contact tracing and on this front we're
making good progress right across the
country municipalities dealing with
reopening ZAR also strapped for cash
forced to consider cuts to services on
Monday the Prime Minister promised
what's essentially a 2.2 billion dollar
cash advance far short of the 10 to 15
billion dollars city say they need Donna
Abigail Beeman in Ottawa thanks here's a
snapshot of the case numbers across
Canada tonight more than 700 new cases
have been confirmed today most are in
Ontario and Quebec in Ontario officials
say at least 80 pardon me 80 of today's
404 new cases are migrant workers who
contracted the virus in southwestern
Ontario a number of other provinces
including New Brunswick recorded no new
cases that's significant for New
Brunswick it's dealing with a new
outbreak that involves a doctor who
contracted the virus in Quebec and
failed to self isolate when he got home
he kept working a total of 12 people
have now tested positive as a result of
that that includes five in a long-term
care facility near campbellton in
Ontario an investigation has been
launched into outbreaks inside long-term
care facilities Ontario's Ombudsman says
he decided to invoke his authority to
investigate after reading last week's
disturbing military report on conditions
inside five hard-hit homes
the investigation will look at issues
that led to the crisis and recommend
ways to help fix the system according to
the province more than 1,400 long-term
care residents have died in Ontario
since the start of this pandemic there's
a preliminary report on what caused last
month's deadly snowbirds crash in
Kamloops BC investigators say it may
have been a bird strike that brought
down the jet in the preliminary report
officials say video taken during takeoff
showed a bird flying very close to the
Jets right engine intake you can see the
here circled in red shortly after that
the plane veered off course and
plummeted to the ground the snowbirds
public affairs officer captain Jen Casey
was killed in the crash the pilot
captain richard mcdougal survived both
ejected from the jet before it hit the
ground the Air Force says it's
investigating whether the aircraft's
escape system was working properly
protests during a pandemic coming up to
fear about the potential rise in kovat
19 cases
mass gatherings like these protests are
things specifically that we've been told
to avoid but the feelings of outrage and
injustice seem to outweigh the fear of
catching the novel coronavirus
protesters that many of the rallies are
wearing face masks but there are still
concerns US cities will see a surge in
nuke ovid 19 cases in the coming weeks
because of all these people gathered
together the pandemic makes the
situation even more complicated because
data suggests black people and other
minority communities in the United
States have been disproportionately
affected by Kovan 19 we don't know for
certain if that's the case here in
Canada because the government isn't
publicly releasing the information and
the NDP is pushing to change that we
know that there are disparate impacts
when it comes to education health care a
criminal justice employment based on the
color of one's skin and we need the
evidence of that to be able to make
better decisions as Heather Eurex West
explains while this information could be
useful to address the specific needs of
racialized communities but that also
comes with risks the outbreak of the
Cargill meatpacking plant in southern
Alberta was one of the country's biggest
nearly 1,000 workers became infected and
two died almost every one of those
impacted was a recent immigrant or a
member of a visible minority group no
one's talking about it that there is a
crack I call it a crisis with
independent this community advocate
believes kovat 19 is unmasking racial
inequalities across the country but
right now there is no data available to
know for sure in the US the kovat racial
data tracker has found that although
black people in that country account for
only 13% of the population the community
has so far accounted for at least 24
percent of kovat 19 deaths these are
things that we need to know because we
do know that kovat doesn't hit everyone
the same way in Canada data is tracked
by local public health units and there
are a lot of disparities for example
Toronto Public Health began gathering
racial data in late April
but Alberta Health Service
sis says it has chosen not to publicly
report on ethnicity or socioeconomic
status at this time so we're working
really right now with Statistics Canada
and other organizations like Kai High
and the Providence territories really
actively to try and get some of that but
publishing data linking outbreaks to
racial groups can be harmful to this can
lead to concerns about the ways in which
and people are profiled systemic forms
of inequality we definitely need to be
focusing on that the issue for me is
when race is used as a proxy because
even though many of the workers at
Cargill are people of color not all
people of color work at meatpacking
plants still advocates say
vulnerabilities among these groups need
to be better understood what you don't
measure is not important right that's
how it works Heather Eric's West Global
News Calgary
still ahead fireworks light up Japan
skies to lift spirits
you are watching global national the
skies over Japan have lit up in a
synchronized fireworks display designed
to brighten people's moods during the
pandemic over a hundred and forty
fireworks companies participated in the
nationwide event it's time and date were
kept secret until the last minute
fireworks celebrations in Japan are
popular in the summer but may have been
canceled this year thousands of children
went back to school in the UK today the
first time since Britain began its co
bid 19 lockdown in March
many parents though aren't ready to send
their kids back fearing it's too soon
there are warnings by some local
councils about potentially triggering a
second wave the US company behind the
antiviral drug REM des vir says it
appears to help people moderately ill
with kovat 19 but it's not a silver
bullet the results of a phase 3 clinical
trial by Gilead Sciences reveals the
experimental drug improved the symptoms
of patients who were given it for five
days those who took it for ten days also
improved but not significantly from des
Avira's approved in Japan and authorised
for emergency use in some cases in the
US lots of critical data on the trial is
still missing and will be published at a
later date
up next power through peace the glimpses
of hope and unity in the George Floyd
protests
[Music]
there is incredible emotional power in
that video of George Floyd lying on the
street with white officers pinning him
down it's triggered outrage that is
understandable and it's led to the worst
unrest in the u.s. in decades the news
tends to focus on the violence the
lashing out this is much deeper than
that
Mike Armstrong looks at the message that
shouldn't be lost in the mayhem it is
easy to focus on this window smashed
fire set in stores looted this was
Sunday night in Montreal and it happened
in dozens of cities across North America
but there is a danger in focusing on
this you miss what came before
[Music]
now it wasn't peace and love the message
protestors wanted to get out was there's
no denying one of frustration and anger
[Applause]
we want this to stop right across North
America the death of George Floyd under
the knee of a police officer was a spark
to clear a case of police brutality to
see and not be affected not be angry not
want change I'm tired of the narratives
I'm tired of the hashtags
how many tat hashtags what we have I'm
tired of being tired that was the
frustration and the message people took
to the streets over the weekend one that
is unfortunately easy to lose sight of
through the fog of tear gas or hard to
hear over the sound of breaking glass
organizers of the peaceful parts of the
protests knew what could happen and
hoped it wouldn't but staying silent
staying home wasn't an option we are the
change we are the hope the dream the
embodiment of a people who say that
enough to know
enoughenough now there's something you
hear at protests something yelled to the
crowd but a message for the media during
peaceful moments shouts that you won't
see this on the news it's a fair
criticism our lenses tend to point to
the negative but in this case with this
issue it's important the positive be
reflected as well as a reminder that the
message can be missed
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight sure Canada is
Green Lake near 70 mile house in the
caribou region of BC we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to us and
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]